I don't vitamin D is extremely important, especially for cancer patients. I've supplemented for years, but I can never see me at my levels up to where they should be even in the summer when I spend a lot of time outside.
Are there specific things genetically or otherwise whereby doctor and I might want to look?
So, yeah, there are genes or vitamin D or BDR genes that you can look on your report. I don't even know who asks this question, but you can look on your genetic report and see if we have defects in your vitamin D receptor genes, your BDR genes.
And if that is the case, you're going to have a more difficult time keeping your vitamin D levels up and you're going to have to supplement higher doses. There's some people that just have a hard time absorbing and keeping vitamin D and they just have to supplement at high doses. So that might be you.
What are some other possibilities that vitamin D issues when you're taking vitamin D? Well, here it goes. Kind of goes back to should I take things with a fat vitamin D is a fat soluble vitamin taking it with fatty foods can may actually improve the absorption of it.
So you can try that take your vitamin D with fatty foods see if that increases your vitamin D levels make sure you're getting a measured on a regular basis so you know what's going on to that might be the thing.
So, and yeah, those are the that's the main things that I would think of with vitamin D and not getting your vitamin D levels up.
We also see low vitamin D with autoimmune patients real common.
So check it if you have an autoimmune condition would be a wise thing to do that would be running the Syrex array five and array seven X Syrex array five and array seven X that would be another thing to look at.
And if you have not done a complete wellness panel that will measure thyroid antibodies so you're looking for antibodies if you have self antibodies AKA an autoimmune disorder that tends to gobble up vitamin D levels as well.
Vitamin D is a is an immune regulatory agent started immune stimulant so when it's needed for regulation of immune system in an autoimmune patient when they get these fluctuations of this immune attack on cells it could gobble up their vitamin D levels.
So, almost all autoimmune patients especially ones that don't know that they're autoimmune and we trust that they'll have fairly low vitamin D levels even if they're taking vitamin D so I would investigate that as well.